it is time for in a minute now you may
have seen Ross and I playing the mobile
game Bingo Blitz and I'm thrilled
because we are teaming up with them
because I have always loved the game of
bingo growing up I went to the bingo
hall every week and now I get to share
the fun with all of you guys yeah and we
get competitive and Drew we actually
found someone who says that she loves
Bingo Blitz even more than you do so
today the two of you are facing off
right now in a live game Let's welcome
Wendy Yarbrough hi Wendy
you are a Bingo Blitz fanatic as well I
am okay and what makes you think you
love it even more than Drew so I've been
playing for years oh dear um one of my
students introduced me to it years ago
and
um they love it and I know I do I think
it's fun just to sit and relax and it's
the best interesting that you find it
relaxing I'm like a cat on Halloween
that's like like that's how I Bingo
Blitz but um I love this app so much
also because it is Global Connections
you can play with anyone around the
world and you can play for free so that
has my heart yeah and it offers this
like for experience of classic Bingo but
it's full of all these surprise features
and just like the Avatar of me that's
right I have an avatar in the game and
it will help you progress as you play
all right well we're gonna play right
okay
[Applause]
I'll call it 916 Wendy
I don't have it Drew
[Applause]
I'm 29 Drew that's another one for you
you have that too oh 74.
and the winner is Wendy and surprise
Wendy our show's Gonna Give You 500
bucks
[Applause]
I'm really happy for you and I'm very
impressed by your game Wendy excited all
right if you guys want to join the fun
like I said it is free we played on the
iPads today but you can play on your
phone that's where I always play and you
just download it from the app store or
on Google Play and Wendy congratulations
I'll probably buy some things for my
classroom
well guess what it just went up to five
thousand
[Applause]
[Music]